où
[Musique]
ils sont les seuls français à des
centaines de kilomètres à la ronde
alors m dans l'enclos pour faire la
pesée
du coup on se met derrière le troupeau
et on crie chaud chaud il nous a fallu
des heures de route pour les trouver au
coeur de la mongolie
bonjour tu vas bien je vais bien merci
leur diplôme d'ingénieur agronome en
poche maxime et lolita ont quitté leur
confort occidental pour le confort plus
rustique des éleveurs mongols une
expérience qu'ils nous ont fait partager
à l'autre bout du monde elles deux ans
jamais j'aurais imaginé que je serai ici
avec cette équipe au milieu des steppes
en train de frapper les moutons par les
pattes pour les peser
dans les steppes mongoles nous avons
aussi suivi alexandre zurcher
organisateurs d'expédition à moto
j'aime enseigner par les grands espaces
cette nature à perte de vue à travers ce
salon
oui pour vernon et steven d'hilda riant
l'un de ces guides il est arrivé il ya
six mois en mongolie un pays grand comme
trois fois la france où la densité de
population est la plus faible du monde
300 en symbiose avec la nature au milieu
de nulle part il ya deux habitants au
kilomètre carré
des animaux partout on peut que se
sentir bien
[Musique]
oulan bator la capitale entre
gratte-ciel et quartier nomades
nous avons rencontré yannick un breton
des côtes d'armor venu pour la première
fois il ya 20 ans juste après la chute
du communisme
six cent mille habitants qui vivaient
ici maintenant il ya un million trois
cent vingt ans il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont venus de la campagne les
immeubles qui se construisent partout
mais je sais pas si pour satisfaire
toute la demande
[Musique]
la mongolie attire les amateurs
d'authenticité et de sensations fortes
ces français nous ont ouvert les portes
de ce grand pays coincé entre la russie
au nord et la chine au sud
parcourir les steppes c'est la vie
quotidienne de lolita et maxime il
travaille pour deux associations
françaises qui aide les nomades à
améliorer leurs techniques agricoles il
leur faut parfois faire dix heures de
route pour les rejoindre c'est ça qui
rend le voyage est encore plus
intéressant est encore plus excitant
c'est fait que ralentir peut-être que là
on va crever les nulle part et on sait
pas encore peut-être est-il croquer dans
une rivière enfin il peut arriver plein
de choses voilà des petits shorts sur
plein de surprises ce matin ils ont
rendez vous avec un éleveur qu'ils
connaissent bien bonjour tout le monde
va bien
balas et d'allemagne m donc elle va avec
qui on travaille maintenant depuis deux
ans sur le programme génétique avec sa
femme tu es mis un beau manteau ils sont
habillés pareil
à 26 ans maxime a choisi d'exercer son
métier dans l'un des plus grands pays
d'élevage du monde la marque peut être
un mouton du programme oui oui c'est un
mouton du croisement
pendant ses études maxime a appris à
croiser les races pour améliorer leur
rendement en lait viande ou laine ici
c'est un test grandeur nature pour
rendre ces brebis plus résistantes au
froid des hivers mongol nos animaux du
programme on les a identifiés ils ont
une boucle jaune sur les oreilles et du
coup on peut avoir
ces petits et on prend les les plus
petits
c'est compliqué c'est un petit peu
compliqué
alors comment on fait pour le maintenu
et mobiles non le mets sur les fesses et
on cale ses jambes de chaque côté de
l'animal
et ça marche
échec et ils sont lourds
c'est possible c'est bon signe
avec et plus de 100 artistes 60,36
saison ça c'est la réussite du programme
et c'est que la première année donc donc
voilà donc on va continuer comme ça avec
d'avenium
vous voyez celui ci c'est un agneau qui
n'a pas été croisés il est plus chétifs
que celui que tient maxime sakho est
plus petit hélas beaucoup moins de
l'aisne ils ont dit qu'is l'autre
différence
grâce au croisement des agneaux nous
allons pouvoir augmenter nos revenus
fixes je suis très reconnaissant à
maxime et lolita ils nous ont beaucoup
aidés
je suis là celle adoptée il allait
vraiment rachat elle dit qu'elle va
l'emmener chez elle de voir que les gens
sont contents du résultat moi ça me rend
juste heureuse en fait on essaie de
travailler ensemble et d'améliorer un
peu à la vie de tous les jours et
ce qui est touchant et qui est motivant
en fait maxime et lolita ont adopté le
mode de vie ancestral des éleveurs ont
goal
bichonne
quand ils ne sont pas en mission ils
vivent qui s'ils acceptaient relègue
une petite ville de 18000 habitants à
huit heures de route d'oulan bator
il partage cette petite maison dans un
quartier populaire
a annoncé maxime
et hop bonne société sardines les petits
outils
le confort est plutôt rudimentaire
c'est notre robinet douche on sent
surtout
c'est parfait
après ben ça tourne dans le seau qui est
là et si on oublie de sortir le saut bas
après ça
ça dégouline partout vous vue à la
française où il a la gueule alors
on a choisi vivre à la nouvelle envolée
de l'africom pas si on a pris deux
manettes pc dont on va chercher nos
puits
de quoi réchauffer n'y a pas d'eau
courante
on a comme l'électricité mais si on
regarde bien on est relié aux poteaux
électriques de la rue donc c'est enfin
si on adore ça pour ça
après c'est vrai que l'univers c'est pas
forcément toujours évident parce que
dans un appartement torah toujours chaud
ici si tu te lèves pas quatre heures
dans la nuit pour faire le feu le
lendemain matin il fait moins 20 dans la
baraque donc il ya un peu des
inconvénients l'hiver peut au final deux
et tout ça ça passe
l'hiver il peut faire jusqu'à moins 35
degrés
coup il fait trop beau la
bad et y en a un qui avait avoir un
petit coup de mou bas l autre va être là
un peu pour l'heure booster je pense qu
on se motive aussi pas mal pour dans le
boulot et puis même dans la vie de tous
les jours après que tu peins chercher
l'eau au puits pareil tout seul c'est
pas très compliqué c' est conscient que
ça peut paraître un peu dingue de
français qui habitent ici au milieu de
nulle part en mongolie
pour la défense c'est un peu la remarque
aussi mais quand on se lève et
connaissait de vue c'est quand même
chouette et on est seul sur terre
c'est le début d'une journée de bureau
comme les autres pour maxime et lolita
auprès des tribus nomades
la vie a comme un petit peu de liberté
à 500 km de là c'est une autre mongolie
oulan-bator une des villes les plus
polluées du monde
sur la place centrale trône la statue de
gengis khan le fondateur au 12e siècle
de l' empire mongol l'un des plus
puissants et des plus grand de toute
l'histoire
60% des mongols vivre à oulan bator
beaucoup sont d'anciens nomades qui
habite à la périphérie du centre-ville
c'est dans ce quartier populaire que vit
steven jyles darian
il partage ce terrain avec une famille
mongole voici sa maison c'est une yourte
donc c'est une annotation traditionnelle
mongole avec le poêle à bois parce que
les hivers sont assez rude et deux nuits
sont fraîches steven est lui même un peu
nomade il passe la plupart de son temps
sur la route et s'apprête à partir dans
quelques heures ça c'est un kit de
premiers secours on a un téléphone
satellite en cas d'urgence des fois on
est 200 km du premier hôpital psy a une
vraiment une urgence oui on peut faire
venir on peut faire dire des éco-acteurs
et vous ressentez koala avant de quitter
votre jour trouver dans les steppes de
l'impatience c'est toujours les
dernières heures les plus longues on va
dire je suis surtout curieux de
découvrir les gens avec qui je vais
voyager parce que au final c'est eux qui
font le voyage c'est c'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça que je fais ce métier
c'est pour ça que j'adore c'est ma
passion aussi
en mongolie la saison touristique ne
dure que trois mois le reste de l'année
les températures sont trop basses
alexandre zurcher propose des
expéditions sur des motos anciennes
c'est le dernier voyage de la saison et
il fait déjà froid en paires de
chaussettes de jean les chiens poste de
m on s'inquiète des chartes
henry et eric deux amis de longue date
arrive d'auvergne cette traversée de la
mongolie ils ont rêvé depuis longtemps
il jour de chevaucher pour 3500 euros
tout compris les
ja l'équipe et
eric vous vous attendez à quoi là pour
ce voyage est bas des grands espaces de
l' aventure de la neige
passionné de moto eric embarqué henry
dans ce périple quand tu en rêves parce
que si c'est comme pour lacombe p
ils vont découvrir la mongolie sur ces
engins importés d'inde
la royal enfield une moto mythique
ancien véhicule de l'armée britannique
elle n'a quasiment pas changé depuis les
années 30
déjà c'est de la vieille mécanique donc
c'est une moto qui a vraiment du charme
qui nous permet d'aller au contact des
locaux on n'a pas le sentiment d'arriver
comme des cosmonautes d'être un peu
déconnecté par rapport à l'environnement
que l'on traverse par ailleurs voilà il
roule vraiment un rythme tranquille donc
c'est très agréable
c'est parti pour une aventure de 1000 km
ils vont rouler à côté des chevaux
traverser les kilomètres de step des
paysages à couper le souffle
[Musique]
bon
lagence d'alexandre organise des voyages
en inde au népal et au bouton c'est sa
première saison en mongolie c'est mon
premier repérage j'ai été vraiment
séduit par les grands espaces cette
nature à perte de vue c'était sur divers
qui est quand même assez saisissant on
traverse la moto et je pense que le
voyageur français aujourd'hui quand il
va aussi loin
il cherche ce type de dépaysement ce
type de contact et la mongolie propose
vraiment ça à 100 %
on est scotché par la grandeur et la
beauté des paysages scotché c'est le mot
qu'on se croirait sur une autre planète
pratiquement ya aucune autre trace
d'avancées technologiques ou quoi que ce
soit c'est la nature à plein voilà
après quatre heures de piste
enfin un village
pourquoi ça ne marche pas
satané moto et king crabe
est ce qu'il a besoin d' aide
il demande si on peut t'aider oui venez
m'aider s'il vous plaît
vous revient boutin les graines et
pousses lax dans les salles comme ça
et à primer entretoises
qu'on roule au mieux nulle part on
s'arrête toujours pour leur donner un
petit coup de main
on ne laisse pas au milieu de la fête
c'est toi qui as réparer ça oui c'est
moi c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
heureusement que je vous ai rencontrés
vous êtes très gentil
ce genre de moments vous organiser ses
voyages bah oui c'est clair alors
prévenu sur une partie du voyage donc
voilà que pour ce type de blanc mais
évidemment utile et le contact de la
population et finalement la meilleure
manière de vraiment rencontrer les gens
c'est dans les moments qui sont un peu
imprévues qui se parent encadré dans des
parcours touristiques traditionnels et
balisés
c'est ça l'esprit nomade je pense dans
les nomades ya cette entraide vaut bien
peut-être laurent
marc vazy doucement
merci vous m'avez bien aidé à venir 2 1
si certains découvrent le pays pour la
première fois d'autres français sont ici
depuis bien plus longtemps yannick est
binaire s'est installé à oulan-bator il
ya onze ans et en bon breton il a ouvert
la première crêperie du pays
à son arrivée yannick était directeur
commercial pour une grande entreprise
et la prochaine vague aux secousses je
suis là il y aurait une surprise une
grande surprise
et puis à 60 ans il se lance dans la
restauration
on a loupé une galette en deuil
avec
confit d'oignon est
très très mal en cuisine sont équipés
mongol une française est venue les
formes et les spécialistes un fait ça
bien
nos expériences aujourd'hui ils sont
devenus les rois de la crêpe
donc c'est tout nouveau pour tout
nouveau gt breton je me suis dit on n'a
pas ici c'est une opportunité et donc
j'ai dire enfin une crête et plus
restaurant parce que tant qu'une crème
ne savais pas si ça allait marcher seul
la tête et les deux marche parfaitement
donc c'est super yannick veut faire
connaître le bon goût français
à la nouvelle classe aisée de son pays
d'adoption
c'est surtout l'ambiance conviviale qui
plaît
j'aime bien cet endroit parce qu'il ya
yannick ici
il distrait les clients il est très
amical
et grâce à lui on dit du bien et en plus
il nous fait boire du gros calvados
la première fois qu'il est venu à
oulan-bator yannick était l'un des seuls
étrangers
le pays s'ouvre est tout juste après
l'effondrement du bloc soviétique
et en attend il ya derrière ce jeu pour
ces mêmes pas certains magasins qui
étaient vais pas danser n'y avait rien
donc on ouvrait une porte on se disait
tiriac envoyer une boîte de conserve et
on savait que c'était une épicerie
possédant donc depuis maintenant c'est
devenu une ville européenne quoi pour
certains la mongolie est aujourd'hui
devenu le nouvel eldorado
le pays connaît un boom économique sans
précédent grâce à ses immenses richesses
minières le niveau de vie d'une partie
de la population a explosé et près de
150 français s'ils se réinstaller
c'est dans ce marché fréquenté par des
mongols aisés et des expatriés que
yannick à ses habitudes
et oui les des courses voilà donc ça
c'est une dame qui fournit pas mal de
choses mais comme névé voilà si on
trouve pas encore d'andouille de guéméné
ou de farine de blé noir les produits
importés ont envahi les étals
yannick se souvient d'une époque pas si
lointaine ouvrir un restaurant français
était impensable 3 kg d'orange
48 multi-week
juste avant j'arrivais encore des
tickets d'approvisionnement là pour les
gens et ça lui a grand changement là
entre 80 90 et 95
le jour et la nuit
un gros potentiel pour tous ceux qui ont
des idées de nouvelles idées dans tous
les domaines et c'est pas fini je pense
non je pense que l'agent de petits qatar
là où
de petits saga pour être comme ça
la nuit c'est toulouse bat or qui brille
s'amuse dans les grands hôtels
yannick est invité dans une soirée chic
il est membre du rotary club
hélas la chanson du rotary
change
officiellement le membres se réunissent
pour faire des donations à des oeuvres
caritatives
mais c'est surtout un cercle de notables
on y vient pour renforcer son réseau
c'est vraiment à l'ordre à
plein de gens les gens de qualité dans
tous
les milieux les domaines des politiques
et privés des patrons de l'hôtel ici qui
fait de la fonte export aussi un peu
tout
[Applaudissements]
yannick le breton a réussi à se faire
une place dans ce milieu très fermé
vous savez les knicks et ce genre de
personne qui est connecté avec tout le
monde pense que tu connais yannick oui
bien sûr
[Musique]
et s'il ne passe pas inaperçu c'est
peut-être grâce à son sens du rythme
[Musique]
ses défauts
et où est on
[Musique]
crise
mais si tu m'aimes
ce soir la bonne société de laon bat or
se couchera tard
[Musique]
à 500 km de là on
maxime et lolita prépare une soirée d'un
style très différent
avec eux nous allons découvrir le passe
temps favori des mongols
ce soir les deux jeunes ingénieurs
agronomes maxime et lolita sorte avec
leurs collègues de bureau tu connais
déjà son
allez vas-y chante en eau douce at war
il habite depuis deux ans dans cette
petite ville loin de la capitale ils
vivent à la mongole et partagent la même
passion pour le karaoké
c'est dans un karaoké de là tu peux pas
mieux bah c'est la bonne soirée
[Musique]
un karaoké en cyrillique succès garanti
tu veux que les
petites chansons pop
[Musique]
notre chauffeur écoute en boucle sur 300
parker pourtant depuis deux ans tous les
shows
[Musique]
lui
nous chante revient dix ans c'est bien
j'aime bien les eaux calmes et q3 parce
qu'ils sont écolos
[Musique]
karine à venir au monde solitude morale
où votre soirée les petits concerts en
france
maman kaboul parce qu'eux-mêmes
[Musique]
la chance d'être
m la campagne pour faire la soirée chic
se
remplace pas
ah les cons ça des hommes
[Musique]
à
deux jours après leur départ le groupe
de motards fait escale pour la nuit chez
une famille de nomades
en mongolie tradition oblige en
accueille spontanément les visiteurs
dans la yourte
et où fait comme ses eaux montent à
généralement région
la yourte est un espace fortement
urbanisée
steven a donc ce code de conduite
tellement d'astral sources le départ
les affaires a pas commettre s'est passé
entre les poteaux sans trop en fait de
l'aïe ont jeté des choses en feu montrer
la plante des pieds
et devant peut refuser le lait par
exemple quand vous offre ce qu'on veut
mais allez les nomades de toute façon
savent qu'on a à l'étranger
est ce que tu peux lui demander comment
ça se passe l'hiver ici il sape qui fait
jusqu'à moins 50 degrés l'hiver saygin
bapaume et ils veulent savoir comment
vous vivez
on apprend à vivre avec ce climat
extrême de notre enfance
et c'est très dur car il neige vraiment
tout le temps
quand il neige beaucoup notre bétail a
du mal à trouver de quoi manger
[Musique]
tout ce sont ces dangers
oui
on est à le pays on aime les gens on
aime tout en bon goût de l'iphone
les touristes viennent chercher en
mongolie la simplicité de cette ville
rurale
mais si ça a des dents elle est beaucoup
plus cool que tu mérites à celle là elle
va les taper tout le monde car le toit
toi jour
et le chef de famille est malin il
s'appelle bolt c'est important pour nous
à partir du moment où voyage en mongolie
de faire vraiment découvrir aussi le
mode de vie nomade traditionnel donc
c'est à ces sujets là c'est génial de
voir que des nomades comme nous
accueillent aussi simplement on va
profiter un petit peu aussi de la vie
rurale
comme vous le voyez on nourrit les
cuivres on va peut-être assister avec
erik hauri à la traite des yaks voilà
puis on va profiter de ces endroits qui
absolument magnifique
ça vous dit pas qu'on essaye de filer un
coup de main légal quand les chevaux
harry faut tout ce qu'on veut mais dans
cercle autour et qu'on lève les bras
pour les arts étaient
rassemblés uniquement pour la traite et
la capture les chevaux mongols vivent
tant aux hordes à moitié sauvage
vous avez déjà vu cette méthode pour
attraper les chevaux oui oui aussi des
bas dans les films jodoigne mais à part
ça dans c'est la première fois que je
vois ça
ce matin les motards change de monture
la mongolie est aussi le pays des
randonnées à cheval
vous allez voir les canassons se déroule
dans une ville tranquille c'est un petit
peu plus aucun mouton certes on est très
bien sur la selle pour l'instant on va
tâcher d'y rester
les voilà partis pour une chevauchée en
direction d'un des plus beaux sites
naturels de mongolie
[Musique]
ganic le citadin aime aussi se
ressourcer dans cette mongolie des
steppes presque tous les week-ends il
vient dans cette vallée elle lui
appartient on est 2 en fait à voir toute
cette valise un mongol et moi vous
veillez protéger cet endroit bah oui
c'est bon il ya trop de monde c'est pas
marrant moi j'aime pas on comptait
peut-être faire une petite station de
ski là pour l'hiver avec un truc pour
les enfants on sait pas c'est un projet
mais en fait on fera peut-être ça sympa
riga rose et rose et yannick à rénover
ce chalet abandonné
vous savez rebonds j'ai faim
c'est comme obélix est comme obélix et
un demi verre de muttur
termine ce midi ça bon je recueille
rasées on est combien et 7,8
est ce que tu peux aller me chercher de
l'eau avant le repas une petite partie
de pétanque
[Musique]
yannick a initié son groupe d'amis
y indique apprend à jouer à tous les
gens qu'il invite ici c'est un sport
qu'on ne connaît pas en mongolie mais
quand on apprend on adore
c'est une compétition on devient accro
yannick joue très bien il mène 9 à 0
mais je pense que j'ai toujours une
chance de gagner
tu peux faire des effets tu vois
maintenant essayer de la placer juste à
côté de la mienne
yannick a même lancé le premier club de
pétanque de mongolie il ne compte
aujourd'hui qu'une dizaine de membres
tous très motivés
elle se débrouille bien je dois me
concentrer
on arrive sur des endroits comme ça
voilà un petit chalet sympa comment
comment comme dans les alpes et
autres non c'est ça la vie
pour le groupe de motards c'est bientôt
la fin du voyage
c'est pour avoir des paysages comme ça
il faut faire les fours
voilà les chutes de l'europe c'est ça
très chic de l'ordre
aucun touriste aux alentours la mongolie
c'est aussi ça se retrouver seul dans
des lieux exceptionnels
une beauté naturelle encore méconnu mais
cela pourrait bientôt changer le pays
attire aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
voyageurs
il faut surtout que sa garde son
authenticité y a pas beaucoup de gens
qui viennent visiter en fait la mongolie
et c'est plutôt pas mal les nomades
qu'on croit sur la route c'est vraiment
d l'instant intacts j'aimerais que
sprint changes peur qui reste aussi
nature est intacte que je vais trouver
cette annonce
[Musique]
hier qu'est ce qu'il ya je veux conduire
allez on y va
il arrive à s'amuser avec eux rien tu
vas il a une plume y rigole un bâton il
rigole et ça c'est vraiment beaucoup et
c'est à dire qu'avec avec le rien et
j'arrive à passer une belle enfance
j'ai un caillou dans ma poche
donne
mais donne non c'est de la bouse
le contrat de lolita se termine elle
retourne en france dans quelques mois
j'ai un peu la larme à l'oeil parce que
en tout cas une grande brèche dans le
coeur parce que ces voix là c'est des
gens maintenant qu'ils sont un peu à
notre famille un peu nos amis et et
ouais c'est pas que j'ai pour ce sera
parce que ça m'a même un peu
aller bien lolita on va dans la yourte
c'est une des dernières fois qu'ils se
retrouvent tous ensemble
un moment célébré autour d'une vodka
traditionnelle mongole
lait de vache fermentée et 10 tille
au sens épique
servez lui avait
il habite ici depuis deux ans ils sont
presque devenus mongol comme nous
maxime et lolita ont traversé deux
hivers rigoureux ils ont partagé la vie
difficile des éleveurs ils vivent comme
nous et ils ont réussi à s'adapter ici
les nomades ont fait plus couvrir leurs
portes à maxime et lolita ils leur ont
transmis cet esprit des steppes une ode
à la vie simple ils repartiront avec au
fond d'eux un peu de cette âme nomades
[Musique]